each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so this is a collaborative work so
we have been working on this for the
last six months or six to eight months
or so and it grew out of the grave off
work we were doing last year we have
actually built a low-power cluster you
can see some of the blades there so i
would like to start also a little bit
with a big picture so for the data
intensive scalable computing there are a
bunch of very obvious strengths today so
we have large data sets which are here
but we still don't have obvious
solutions which are just of the shelf
for the scientists that they can just
plug in their code and run and we don't
have a national infrastructure with the
national infrastructure is very CPU
heavy and basically ordered big super
computer centers are just today they are
trying to build basically more io
capabilities into the system generally
the problems that we are facing are such
when the data sets are too big to fit
into memories so we can't use any of the
caching and so on and basically we need
sequential I of one can argue by
sequential io because once we have a
petabyte then and we have to use random
i/o then basically we better work on
cosmological problems because it will
take the age of the universe to finish
it so they only hope to tackle these
problems is to at least you success
sequential IO patterns as we can and
even the high-performance projects today
are starting to choke on Io so basically
the largest hydro simulations or
cosmological simulations as i will show
they are limited essentially by this
place and i/o bandwidth rather than
actually the science needs so scientists
would like to run much bigger
simulations if they can there is also a
emerging sociological trend data
collection is done in ever-larger
collaborations like the virtual
observatory so you can think of the
Sloan Digital Sky Survey LSST or neon or
or the oceanography projects
so basically what these collect focus
and collect the data and then the
archive the data and most of the analyst
is decoupled from so this is a
disruptive change in science so so
basically science will be done on the
archive data sets in much smaller groups
typical data sets that are challenging
today are now reaching the hundred
terabyte range they were in the tens of
terabytes a year or so ago and today
they are hitting the hundred terabyte
range and in a very shortly so probably
in about a year we will are we are going
to hit the petabyte scale that that will
be that we consider difficult and
challenging so basically we need to
build petascale database facilities in
and that are also easy to use scientists
are cheap so we will never buy EMC
systems and so we typically if we have a
budget we would like to maximize the
amount of funds so we would like to
build our own from cheap of the shelf
components so interesting to see that a
very similar vacuum led to the emergence
of the bear wolf in computing about 10
years ago where the super traditional
super computer system just didn't do the
job that scientists wanted to use and
the same attitude led to so once Tom
sterling produced a recipe that build
your own people embrace the bear wolf
idea vary widely but how can we classify
what is data intensive and what is not
so I would like to go back to
undisclosed sort of due to a paper that
we wrote still with Jim and in
particular one of my flaws that under
said that one bit of sec I one bit of
sequential i/o tear sack is needed to
keep a CPU happy at the one instruction
per sec level so basically a system is
armed a balanced if we have one bit of
eye of per instructions and so one can
compute this ratio so I did this or we
did this in this paper and this is
basically the am dial number for a bunch
of different systems so for a typical
bag of cluster it's about point oh eight
so for a power desktop that people can
put a bunch of disks in it
nds highest point to then again for the
amaz this is the cloud vm is the amazon
cloud so there was a paper which was
trying to read from amazon s3 on
multiple stripes and basically they
could get about 20 megabytes per sec
from the india muslim virtual machine SC
1 is deliver more and I think sc2 was
real numbers given to me by Ralph and of
course these are all dependent on how
many i/o notes you stick on the machines
but this degree are really typical for
today's super computers and I think this
work is actually way ahead of the pack
so this is a system that we built at
Hopkins with that we call the gray wolf
tears and our number of point five and I
know of one system that is commercially
used that is the arm that is the ebay
system that has an unknown number of
point 86 so but they have 120 describes
per server where and these are all
15,000 RPM drives so they have a
different order of magnitude many orders
of different magnitudes by Justin we do
so what is nice about the under number
that you cannot you can also compute it
for data sets so these are some of the
simulations so the Aquarius is a
cosmology simulation done in Munich so
you can take the size of the data and
the number of CPU cycles that was
required to compute it ok and Aquarius
was done in Munich vile actia was done
by piero model at oakridge and this is a
friend of mine did the material science
simulation on the terra grid and so
typically the color codes that these are
than the under numbers of the typical
super computer hardware on which these
simulations were on these tasks were
these data sets were processed and ran
on a bare wolf that's the green arrow
here so that's what the hardware can
produce and these are the data sets that
were generated and these are different
logs so this was based on the query logs
from the sloan digital sky survey
database machines so we can see that on
the database machines with pretty much
saturated the hardware and on the other
machines as we went a little bit away so
there is an increasing and there is an
increasing gap basically between so as
we go to higher and higher and system
the gap between the hardware and even
the actual data sets is growing bigger
and bigger and it's interesting to
understand why once we look at the data
set sizes in each of those simulations
and basically everybody is today stuck
between 10 and hundred terabytes so so
so these simulations could actually use
they would be happy to output and
utilize more of the i/o bandwidth on the
supercomputers if there was more scratch
base than 20 or 30 terabytes but in
oakridge they couldn't get so espero we
are currently working on the next
simulation where he would do 20
terabytes at the time then we transfer
it to hopkins then we do another 20
terabytes and we would build up
essentially a 500 terre by data set for
echoes models for for a next-generation
cosmological simulations there is only
one petabyte data set is been stars and
actually this is still not there in a
year it will be there so it's already
kind of putting out the system is
already put in our data but it's not
producing yet and you can see even
everything else or the song queries when
I add it all up it's sort of between 10
and 100 terabytes so how can we build in
a practical terms today using cheap
components how can we build a scalable
and data-intensive architecture so that
I'm not talking about the 200 million
dollar range but something that the
university group can have for it so this
is a project that we really started out
with Jim so we were on this pass for
many years and so we decided to us in
Denver came up with the name Graywolf
combining the werewolf idea with Jim's
name so this is a crosstab f of light
cluster of database nodes which are very
disk heavy and I Oh heavy and we are
exactly using locally locally attached
disk so exactly the way now we heard in
the previous talks so the goal was to
build a machine with a very high under
number using modular commodity
components so we have 50 servers roughly
one petabyte of
disks 500 CPU and the ddr InfiniBand we
have a 10 gigabit lambda uplink to UIC
so we can move data in and out and we
have been implementing various reference
projects in funding came from the most
mostly from the Moore Foundation
Microsoft and pen stars but so first of
all we demonstrated we built a 200 terre
by database from the Sloan and which and
the demo of this this demo one the
storage challenge industria
supercomputing so what we were able to
show that the aggregate iowa scale to a
over 70 gigabytes per second on the
system so one and a half gigabytes per
second per node but when we run database
queries they came close to the speed of
light so they came they became within
seventy-two percent of the raw iOS speed
of the subsystem using sequel server oh
does very cost efficient so one gigabyte
per second bandwidth costs us about ten
thousand dollars which is much better
Nettie's us as a system that they can do
similar io speeds but at a million
dollars for 10 terabytes or so the
unknown number is point five six but
basically we were hitting the power wall
so we build the system put it into the
physics lab that was converted to a
computer room and then essentially we
ran out of power and so right now the
building is undergoing a reconstruction
we are bringing in new transformers two
hook up yet another lab so that we can
add another petabyte next year but after
that we will run out of the juice that's
coming into the building so we were
already building with under us little
wireless modes that measure this clamp
on meters that can measure the power in
each circuit in the room so that we can
actually understand the time the temper
of dependence of our workload and maybe
we can do some fancy power management
and so on they also have hundreds of
Microsoft build temperature sensors in
the computer room and anyway so so the
power is becoming the main concern so
how can we do better
Along Came solid state disks so around
Christmas time they start the process
starts to come down to the acceptable
ranges and the new solid state is
basically ocz and Intel can perform a
250 megabytes secretary Reed 200
megabytes per second sequential right
and want to a toot 122 watts power so
that is very attractive and even now you
can write them enough times that that
essentially day lifetime is less of a
concern so how have been people trying
to use these solid state disks so there
are several companies which are trying
to put SSDs or flash memory into
existing haiyan service so there are a
bunch of PCI base cards where you put in
so the fusion-io and those is is
building those that can do eight hundred
megabytes a second but basically even if
we put like three of this disruption an
existing high-end rate card it saturates
the red card at that point so and then
shortly after if you can start putting
more cards into the PCI slots and we
said we saturate the PCI bandwidth and
so then they have to add another
expensive server to this so we have
decided to take an orthogonal approach
or the opposite approach so scale down
again back to Jim's ideas build the
bricks the cyber bricks that Jim talked
about more than 15 years ago so that
take a nom de blade so on the blade is
basically one SSD pack or try to take
some of the attack try to take advantage
of some of these very low-power
motherboards and it turns out when we do
this when we look at these basically so
the ocz vertex is a typical drive so 120
gigabytes 250 megabytes a second 10,000
I ops and roughly 300 it was actually
three hundred dollars in March notice
about 400 so the trend is such that
there is now suddenly such an exploding
demand for ssds that there is a premium
on them so in order when we are
preparing now for supercomputing we had
trouble we have to go like five
different web stores to buy tendras here
tendrils there
because it was out of out of stock
everywhere anyway low-power motherboards
so there are some other Bose I will show
a little bit more about this but you can
get to their motherboards which are you
are course at 1.6 gigahertz at 28 watts
or so and the combination if we just do
the rough numbers 200 megabytes per
second pair 1 it's 1.6 gigabits per
second when they combined it with the
1.6 eage hurts so basically it's a nom
de number of one so we looked at a whole
bunch of different boxes so we looked at
an asus for example an asus eee box that
is a three-hundred-dollar box you can
bite off amazon so that has a single
atom core in it then inter has a dual
core board zotac has the board with the
ion chipset axiom Tech has a pickle
motherboard which is really tiny and it
uses an internship set which is supposed
to take only five watts it actually
takes 15 oh and then there was the Alex
experiments here at CMU which we are
using the SN AMD Alex eight hundred or
so yeah so it's a whole variety of
different CPUs and configurations and
these are some of the quantities first
of all a bunch of columns so this is the
cpu speed aggregated over the number of
course times the clock cycle so i didn't
come flops or anything did something
that is simple this is the memory in
gigabytes or this is sequential i/o
using too so all these systems use two
solitudes they disk and the Alex was
using just a flash card this is the
random i/o in the I ops in thousands of
I ops this is the total amount of disk
space in terabytes this is the power in
watts and this is the cost the cost
includes the hardware then I hold up
Hopkins physical plant and ask them what
do they what do we pay for a kilowatt
hour so for us it is actually 15 cents
per kilowatt hour in Baltimore and then
we multiply it
by 1.6 they took this from James
Hamilton's papers so for the AC overhead
and the price assumes that the 250
gigabyte SSD by this fall would have
been four hundred dollars it didn't
happen because of this car City issue so
that's a little bit optimistic but that
only affects this capacity column we can
still buy a hundred and 2000cc for 400
and 400 so basically we can get it
doesn't impact the i/o speed because
that's the same for the drives of the
different capacity so we can get one
gigabyte per second sequential io for
2400 so if already today it's a factor
of 4 better than on the gray wolf Oh
scaling so this is actually so we try to
take down this chart and scared it to a
couple of where we kept one of the
factors constant and for comparison so
let me just look through it very quickly
so one the first column was to fix price
so at a constant price so for the price
and always compared to the grave of so
that's our fiducial node so let's see so
forth so the total ownership of a
variable node is nineteen thousand
dollars this says at how many notes of a
particular kind cost the same amount so
for the price of one brief would note we
could buy 16 of the zotac for example
and then for the 16 notes the aggregate
sequential I of performance would be 8
gigabytes per second compared to one and
a half at the power of 400 or 500 watts
against 1150 but what is more
interesting is the constant sequential I
oh so how many of these little boards do
I need to be basically the big server
the number is three and so at the cost
of roughly thirty five hundred dollars
or so I can build a system that has one
and a half gigabytes per second and at
90 watts our consumption and
what is also interesting that there is a
sweet spot actually this arrow should
have come down here there is a sweet
spot no there it no it's at the right
place sorry so basically in the
sequential I oh when I go these issues
and the Intel sorry the asus motherboard
is a single core atom and that that
doesn't perform anywhere as well as they
do our core so it just a single item is
not good enough essentially to handle
the vio and then when we scaled down far
there then the performance is wrapping
very rapidly so so so there is a sweet
spot basically the you are corazon is
today the sweet spot and this will of
course change with subsequent
generations of a hybrid is that we take
so the sum of the motherboards have
three or four SATA ports so that I
started mixing essentially to settle 20
20 CC drives and a bunch of Samsung's
which are still low power regular hard
disk so and then we can also add
capacity at relative at at a moderate
increase of power so we mix essentially
those two so scaling sorry let me go
back stealing to constant power if I
scale to constant power to the dome so
then essentially for again for the same
power we can buy thirty eight of the of
the zotac of the autumn boards basically
need as much power as a single gray wolf
and at that point I have something like
a factor of fifteen higher sequential io
speed so this is I think probably for
deployment for data in terms of where I
intensive performance this is kind of an
interesting number that if I power if
I'm power constraint going this way I
can basically increase my io
capabilities by a factor of fifteen or
sixteen today on today's prices and the
constant disk size is where we are
suffering essentially in order to match
the i/o capacity of the grave of today
we would need 45 notes and that would be
pretty expensive so this would be like
thousand dollars versus 20 although the
difference is much less so it's only a
factor of four today and so there's an
interesting number then I run the
spreadsheet that how expensive wood s750
gigabyte hard disk be that to be cheaper
to essentially beat this hard disks even
on this scale it turns out at 400 s as
soon as the SSDs cross over this limit
it will be cheaper to build this SSD bae
systems and this can't be too far out
little effect you know maybe maybe here
so status so we compared all these
motherboards we are building the 50 node
cluster that should cost less than 50k
it helped that we got a whole bunch of
motherboards from Nvidia but I will
still include it in the price or so with
tools is a vertex drive we can
definitely get 500 megabytes per second
sequential read to 400 megabytes a
second sequential write in 20,000 i opes
at certain what's so there's a bottom
line but the ion actually the ion
chipset that nvidia built they built it
for the apple TV box so it has a bunch
of GPUs on it so that they can do
high-definition TV on this which the
autumn couldn't do it itself oh so it's
also the only about slope our mother
board that can run on four gigabytes of
memory and in principle the ion chipset
has 40 memory pins so it can run home Oh
much bigger memory it has 4 theta so
three regular theta and one is a DA one
external theta and it has 16 of these
stream processors so the motherboard
runs around 28 to 30 watts but what is
particularly attractive about this that
since the ion chip itself is also the
memory controller for the whole system
it has a unified memory space ok so the
autumn sits in the same memory space as
the GPU we don't have to copy through
the PCI bus the data in so this is quite
beautiful and cuda now support something
so the whole cuda FBI has a second
calling the zero copy option that
instead of passing the data to a texture
map back I can provide a point there so
I don't have to copy so this is
something really nice ya know the dead a
single chip that contains all the all
the normal internships that
functionality plus 16 GPUs so the
standard chips that does basically a
memory controller I of control pci bus
sound card video output and the end the
mvd are also shoved in basically 16gb of
course okay and immediate run also still
at a low power and in so the beauty of
this that that this is so you need only
these two chips to build a motherboard
and an nvidia already demo'd also a
pickle motherboard that is the same size
as a laptop this drive so so ten by
seven and a half centimeters let's
really remarkable yeah yeah so basically
they can be max out the motherboard with
two SSDs when we had the third one then
essentially the autumn starts to choke
oh we basically just use the built-in
gigabit internet no but no but but
that's not actually so the typical
e-science applications are typically
scanning through lots of data and if we
can run some the first pass of the
science analysis code right as we read
the data of the disk at that stage we
can then decimate or or even so roughly
want ten to one percent survives
hopefully the first pass and then we are
in the in the right ballpark with the
gigabit and then again the aggregate
network bandwidth is then 50 gigabits
per second across the cluster still okay
so there are we yeah so we are playing
with so one row on this shelf that we
are building will be different dis
configurations so we can compare the two
candidates that we are playing with
Samsung drives which are one terabyte
128 megabytes per second but 7200 RPM
but the seven huh
and a half what and the laptop version
of this which take only two and a half
wats 450 500 gigabytes and so the
projections that we can really it's
basically the motherboards which will
max out the system so we are running low
level benchmarks right now planes with
scalability we are comparing various
real-life applications so we are trying
to run CUDA from sequel server and that
was actually pretty tricky so we as we
learn the hard way first of all so let
me if I have not I have probably two
minutes so one problem was first we
plugged in the board and then who'd I
didn't come up because we didn't have a
display plugged in so we had to trick
windows windows installed if we didn't
see a display plugged in it it believed
that it installed a virtual display
driver so we had to build a little blog
with 375 on grassy stores on the RGB
output so that was one then we turned on
the remote desktop so that we can access
the cluster remotely ok huda went away
so it turned out that again if you r DB
our desktop in then windows installs
again a virtue of the display driver but
luckily VNC on the other hand does a
screen capture on the hardware card so
we are running now B and C and then
finally be locally installed will wrote
a script that installed windows 7 on all
the machines and then essentially sequel
server and could have crashed so they
try to install in the same service slot
so it turns out that we can do this on
XP so we are now back to X before now
until and video is kind of patching up
the CUDA framework but basically so did
it was hardwired both into sequel server
and into who the twins to use the same
service slot in vista and later so so it
was but we got it working so the idea is
to take 300 million galaxies from throne
and compute photometric redshifts which
is running a random forest regression
tree analysis your computing 50
regression trees per object and
typically this takes a week on a
reasonable size class there today we
seem that we can using this combination
can actually do it in about 20 minutes
on this class there just to demonstrate
that we can do real life problems
summary science community is starving
for storage and aisle we need some
objective metrics for these systems to
clearly separate the from the cpu
intensive architectures and also this
can be used to characterize our
computational problems that what
problems are adequate for what
architectures current architectures
cannot say much farther primarily
because of the power issue so we cannot
just buy more disks and more servers
because at least at universities we
cannot so Google can afford to do it
Microsoft can afford to do it Hopkins
cannot so the future is in low power and
photo and architectures very much along
the line of Iranian Garces talks and
this represents the host novel sets of
system challenges if I wanted to catch
the capture distance on bytes so
basically yesterday high-end computing
was about see few cycles so today it is
really about data access and tomorrow it
will be entirely about low power thank
you
that's going to multiply the number down
it down while more narrows our joint
well it depends on how you partition
your data so the magic is in the
partition and of course Microsoft is a
little paranoid position is for in that
way so to have a massively scale that's
it would serve as but the app's rating
yeah yeah yeah but but again I think
whenever as we scale down down and out I
think we can use cheaper network
adapters because if I shop a lot of
bandwidth into a science river then i
also have to increase my network
bandwidth proportionately but that gets
disproportionately more expensive as if
I go to a quad speed InfiniBand and then
and I have been also been to envy plan
driver house so so that's another not
not a good place to be other questions
and let me open up to questions for any
of these people oh if not better good so
you showed a limitation on the ISS
queries and about the harder
so first one at the end yeah yeah so for
example you know bum classic example was
so last year so lost here the problem
including the real act problem to
demonstrate on the power of the plaster
was a real life previous was running
archive and into the multistage virtual
what it essentially next optical systems
within the circuits are beginning to end
on the plus side we were able to run
construction so obviously people would
want to use that craftiness of the
shipping fee and for other they ask for
more and then they would ask to work
harmoniously Univision whereas a brain
decreasing at Univision heart attack in
the river
application to running the same were
broadly designed educational
I think I think we will see more
heterogeneity in the architecture than
DC now but if we wanted to leverage
commodity components it cannot we cannot
go way too much okay so one technology
is indeed you know the emerging media to
GP GP of everything that's obviously is
going to here to stay I think it has
this to be done at a lower power and
I've I understand Nvidia's working very
hard to actually scale down and who
knows what happens to a lot of it comes
up so so that is here to stay definitely
I think solid state disk side are
probably going to be here for probably
five to ten years until the next set of
physical devices coming which would
supersede medical / it's better physical
properties and then they go out to the
door and as if kind of hard tapes tapes
are out so obviously and a hard disk are
probably here for the next few years
until also we have run businesses these
long enough that busy day for their
homes time I think that unfortunately
there's lots of people who mike has a
rather than reform yeah more either by
capacity and performance so yeah well
this designing for performances and
vomit early others the damn with writing
for some applications Delta system she
was filtering or but capacity 10
speculation that I've begun to see is
the lil secret high-end systems
essentially two clusters where the
second cluster is the storage subsystem
for the first cluster the first cluster
is the bigger one compute oriented and
we do data analytics in our second
cluster close to the data yeah and I
should have mentioned that Hopkins in
the same room understanding the events
which we have a 2000 cpu barrow prospere
which we can basically do be able to
peer to any of the database house so
yeah I pull it
ok so i think have a 10 minute break and
for the erjin presentation so let's make
all three speakers